JESSICA DENE
EARLEY-CHA: Giving users
a personalized experience is key
to building successful actions.
A simple thing, like
getting permission
to use your user's name and
email, can be a game changer.
With those data
points, you can keep
track of that particular
user's preferences
and provide them with a richer
and more customized experience.
For example, you could save
your user's food preferences
when they've signed
into your actions
so you could provide better
recommendations in the future.
A frictionless way to do
this is through what's
called account linking
with Google Sign
In for the Assistant.
Actions on Google offers
three different account
linking types--
Google Sign In, OAuth only,
or OAuth and Google Sign In.
Let's explore the different
scenarios for each option
and how to implement them.
For the Google Sign In, your
user's ID is managed by Google,
so you don't need to
build an account system
or worry about OAuth.
This type of account linking is
great for standalone actions,
and if you are
already using Google
Sign In for mobile or web.
Google Sign In for
Assistant is just
like Google Sign In
for any other platform.
As the user is engaging
with your action,
you tell Google
when to ask a user
if they want to share
their basic information
with your action.
If the user agrees to
share their information,
the assistant will
send an ID token
with each following request.
The ID token is
cryptographically
signed by Google.
You'll need to code it
using a JWT decoding library
and Google's public key.
You verify it by checking
the token's issuer is
the value of your client ID.
Then, you use the JSON
that contains a user's name
and email address.
If you're using
our client library,
we handle this for you--
pretty sweet.
If the user does not consent to
share their profile information
with your action, you should
still provide the best service
that you can without associating
an identity with the user.
The second account
linking type is
OAuth, which supports two
industry standards OAuth
two flows--
the Implicit and
Authorization Code Flows.
You might want to consider
using a [INAUDIBLE] if you have
an existing implementation
of an OAuth server,
and you cannot extend the end
points to support Google Sign
In protocols.
We do discourage using OAuth
only for conversational actions
because it requires transferring
the user from voice to screen,
which increases user's friction.
The last account linking
type is a combination
of OAuth and Google Sign In.
Imagine you have an
existing application
and you allow signups using
multiple identity providers,
not just Google.
You may have existing user data
if, for example, your users
already have a loyalty card or
membership with your service.
You want to allow users
to engage with your action
and connect their Google
account with your already
existing account that uses a
non-Google identity provider
account in your system.
To allow for this,
you'll want to implement
OAuth and Google Sign In.
This combines Google Sign
In with the standard OAuth
flow used as a fallback.
So during that
account linking flow,
you tell Google to
prompt the user.
Ask them if they want to
share their basic information
with your action.
If their Gmail email
isn't in your database,
you'll provide one of
two options to the user.
The first option is to support
account creation via voice,
which immediately creates
a new account using
the data contained in
the Google ID token.
The second option is disallowing
account creation via voice.
If you choose this
option, the Assistant
sends the user to your
web log in on their phone.
So you could use your
authentication system
to log them in with
a different account.
You'll want to use the
first option, supporting
account creation
via voice, if you
want to minimize friction of
the account creation flow.
You want to use a second
option, disallowing
account creation
via voice, if you
need full control of the
account creation flow,
or if you want to maximize the
chances that the user will link
to their existing account
instead of creating
a new duplicate account.
Connecting their account
to a non-Google account
is important in
cases where you want
to provide different
experience options
or if you're logging
their activities that
would affect the user later.
As mentioned before,
this is helpful
if you have a loyalty program.
For example, you
want to keep track
of any points they earned
during their experience
using your action when
there are existing accounts.
The OAuth and
Google Sign In flow
gives you the highest
thinking conversion rate
because your Google users get a
streamlined linking experience
while other users
that are registered
using another account type
can still link their account
and sign into your service.
These are the different
ways to implement account
linking so you can
create fantastic actions.
Interested in learning
more about account linking?
We've added some resources
in the description below.
We also have an
active community.
So you can ask your questions
and share your ideas
with everyone.
Let us know what you build on
Twitter by using the hashtag
AoGDevs.
I'm Jessica Dene Earley-Cha.
Thanks for watching.
And I look forward to
seeing you use account
linking in your actions.